en fait qui complètement hallucinant là
dedans c'est que j'ai vraiment
l'impression de jouer à un jeu de type
call of duty
trek la manche dans une partie digne et
quand on y réfléchit je me dis que je
suis dans un silence est hyper sérieux
parce que c'est vraiment les outils
utilisés par l'armée de terre pour
s'entraîner pour se coordonner
c'est ouf
[Musique]
à votre avis est ce qu'on dit alors on
n'est pas dans une salle de jeux en
réseau
quoique on ira était alarmé terre au
coeur l'armée de terre pour parler
d'entraînement stratégique sur ce qui
pouvait ressembler effectivement je vous
l'accordé une salle de jeux en réseau
sauf qu'en réalité on n'y est pas du
tout on est vraiment dans un lieu qui
personne n'a jamais accès d'ailleurs
c'est je pense la première fois dernière
fois de ma vie que j'ai eu accès on a
plein de machines pour s'entraîner à
différentes simulations situation
d'entraînement c'est très sérieux
c'est l'armée de terre vous allez voir
c'est complètement hallucinant il a
besoin d'être dans un salon gaming mais
c'est pas du tout à ça on gaming c'est
très sérieuses et l'armée ouais alors
qu'ils et vous qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
donc je suis le chef de bataillon
guillaume je suis officier programme à
la section technique d'ordinaire c'est à
dire que j'exprime le besoin des
utilisateurs pour
auprès des industriels de l'enfance
derrière on a bu spartacus voilà
d'accord spartacus est un des projets
que je conduis d'accord donc c'est un
simulateur 3d basé sur un jeu vidéo
addition de commerce et sur lequel la
section technique de l'armée terre
développe des outils particuliers pour
répondre aux besoins de préparation
opérationnelle des petits et chantal tic
sont des unités d'un volume de 2,8 à 200
200 combattants teint quand même donc ça
veut dire qu'on a une base de jeu vidéo
réel qu'on peut trop de commerces
voilà quel type de jeu vidéo aujourd'hui
alors une fille c'est exactement ça
le logiciel continue ça fait ps3 est
issu du jeu arma pour les
z qu est ce qu elles ce sont les copies
des roches droite amant ok sur l'autre à
nine et ensuite avec votre souris en
main droite
vous avez votre ok ça marcherait sa
ceinture et sur ce jeu on développe des
outils d'administration à distance pour
soulager les militaires dont ce n'est
pas le métier de aux contingences de la
gestion d'une plate forme informatique
quai des outils de mise en réseau pour
permettre aux cavaliers d'un régiment de
s'entraîner avec des fantassins dans un
autre régime en tout ça dans le même
environnement et enfin à utiliser les
ont le couple avec les systèmes
d'information opérationnels qui sont
basiquement les ordinateurs que nous
avons sur nous dans nos véhicules et qui
me permet de savoir où et l'ami ou
l'ennemi
quel est votre potentiel en munitions en
carburant
les qui me permettent d'envoyer des
ordres recevoir dix ans donc ça veut
dire que la personne cavalière poste va
s'entraîner ou de la stratégie en fait
pour qu'elle soit présente exactement
donc on distingue bien l'entraînement
technique qui correspond à apprendre à
se servir d'un d'une arme ou d'un
système d'armes et d'entraînement
tactique qui correspond à le
le mettre en oeuvre avec des
subordonnées avec des supérieurs et donc
dans le cet entraînement tactique on
entraîne les gens à une relation de
commandement entre leurs subordonnés et
leur supérieur par exemple entre un chef
de section et son commandant d'unité et
on va entraîner et dérivés les
procédures tactiques et des échanges
d'ordre entre c'est entre ces deux
personnes terrorisées deux personnes
ensemble
voilà pour qu'elle ait des échanges
d'optimiser exactement hockey
[Musique]
on est vraiment dans les conditions du
réel là dessus on peut être dans les
pires conditions possibles
sympathique en place et labinal
observateurs l'observateur avec son
désignateur nazaire donc lui il a
distancé à peu près à kelly sens de
l'objectif il est à 220 il ya 200 mettre
d'accord sur la place du conducteur je
me suis mis en en vue troisième personne
ce que je peux aussi bloqué pour un
entraîné pour éviter que il voit plus
que ce qui ne devrait en voir
normalement oui si je suis à la première
personne en tant que chef de pièce est à
côté j'ai mon conducteur d'accord donc
là en gros on prend le poste de deux
personnes une première personne qui va
s'entraîner sur ce poste-là et une
deuxième personne qui va s'entraîner sur
ce poste là pour les faire travailler
conjointement t on le fait en utilisant
des automates qui permettent de ne pas
convoquer l'ensemble des subordonnés si
vous voulez a entraîné un chef de
section à une section ces trois groupes
de huit personnes et entraîné la
relation entre le chef de section et les
trois chefs de groupe sans forcément
avoir besoin pour autant de convoquer le
reste des cybers données qui vont être
joués par des automates dans le jeu donc
ils ce sont deux personnes physiques qui
elles vont travailler de concert pour
arriver à la même mission
voilà mais en face elles ont affaire à
des automates donc un programme qui va
lui répondre même manière alors elles
ont sous leurs ordres des automates
darritchon le corbeau redonner et
encaisse aussi long des automates qui
joue l'ennemi ils ont aussi aidé comme
voisin d
des automates aussi est-ce que le risque
c'est pas d'avoir une réponse qui a plus
trop écrite du point de vue logiciel et
du coup d'être déconnecté de la réalité
de terrain
est ce qu'un os thomas devra répondre de
la même manière qu'un ennemi est ce que
l'ennemi ne peut pas du coup prendre en
compte ce que ferait l'automate pour
agir différemment alors l'idée c'est de
ce n'est pas de d'entraîner les gens
avec la avoir la même réaction face à
face à un ennemi l'accord guider c'est
plutôt de tard il aidé des procédures
tactique qui sont écrites au préalable
et d une façon de communiquer voilà
c'est plutôt ça donc on va pas
recréer des scénarios systématiquement
on va plutôt entraîner les gens à
communiquer les uns avec les autres dans
un cadre militaire qui sur ces
véhicules-là correspondent à ce que vous
avez en réel culot et fcvq n'a été fait
dans le détachement depuis à la cire
nation de sauvian d'accords cassés
véhicules qui ont été faits en interne
s'alarmer je peux rentrer dans l'édicule
pas trop si vous approchez vous appuyez
sur la touche tu as oui et nous
positionne faisait dans le passé lors
même le détail sur le volant sinon j'ai
pas tari polo orange qui à le dire donc
à votre problème
[Musique]
je vois par exemple votre bureau là vous
avez ici je vois une montre c'est un gps
pas des tees là bas qu'est ce qu'on va
essayer la radio de l'administrateur
d'accord donc là on prend vraiment ce
qu'on a en réel sur le terrain
donc là je veux sortir je fais quoi j'en
fais où je peux lâcher je vais souvent
défaillant
en fait qui complètement hallucinant là
dedans c'est que j'ai vraiment
l'impression de jouer un jeu type call
of duty
très clairement dans une partie digne et
quand on y réfléchit je me dis que je
suis dans un signe au torse et hyper
sérieux parce que c'est vraiment les
outils utilisés par l'armée de terre
pour s'entraîner pour se coordonner
c'est ouf je suis un privilégié
aujourd'hui ce que je peux te montrer
rentrer dans des bâtiments aussi
certains bâtiments sont en fait les
trains d'accord moi pendant s'entraîner
au combat
c'est juste hallucinant c'est grâce à
fanny tout ça c'est fanny qui m'a fait
venir même si menottant rien fait des
concessions
bon ça serait ça se saurait bon bravo
merci famille alors au tout ça c'est
dans le cadre du forum et l'innovation
déférence j'ai du mal à la primaire par
le ministère des armées donc salut à la
cité de la mode et du design le samedi
24 souffert au grand public ce sommet et
vous pouvez vous inscrire battu admettre
le bien qu'ils partagent mon combat dans
la description et je vous invite à venir
nous rejoindre parce que j'y serai il y
aura plein de monstres et hyper
intéressant il y aura une jambe bionique
entre autres avoir 100 gagne peut-être
une cape d'invisibilité d'harry potter
nes québécois vraiment ses claques juste
vous donc vous venez voir il ya plein
d'innovations vous rendez pas forcément
content comme ça mais l'armée en termes
d'innovation c'est juste énorme ce
qu'ils ont là on vous montre des outils
il y en a plein et je pense qu'on va se
marrer
donc on se rend samedi à samedi à samedi
m